for me they were meant to be thrown
around worn everywhere it's something
that you should be wearing you should
live in it and it should tell that story
of your life it's like this personal
journal of experience
[Music]
I'm Savannah Yarborough and we are at
the Atelier Sabbagh studio
one of the first pieces that I designed
when I was working for a bigger company
was a leather jacket it was really flat
and wasn't interesting at all I took the
sample home I put it in my bathtub and I
wore it while it dries it molded to me
it was different from putting on
anything else that I'd ever had I met
people in the factories that were
actually making these jackets and I
learned a lot from those people it's
whether it's a $200 leather jacket for a
ten thousand dollar leather jacket it's
gonna last forever it's going to change
every time they wear it if it rains
you're gonna be okay and your leather
jackets gonna look five times better
when it dries
first phase of making one of our leather
jackets is meeting with the client
select the leather that they want any
embroidery or specific details that they
might also want to add and we actually
draw out the jacket for them after that
you take 32 points of measurement with
the word bespoke the person who's taking
your measurements is also the person
that's with your piece the whole way
through I'm making a jacket that you
will be wearing physically myself I can
only make four jackets a month the
second phase is to create the paper
pattern based on the measurements
these two-dimensional pieces that will
then be put together to create the
actual 3d jacket the armhole and the
shoulder that's the most complicated
place to fit and I've developed a really
great pattern to be able to adapt it for
each person it's a really really
beautiful armhole as a designer that's
the first thing you look at when you
look at it a jacket or a coat like how
beautiful does that sleeve hang we make
a fabric version which is basically a
mock-up of what they're leather jacket
will be there's always some sort of
tweaks that have to be done before we
actually cut once the needle goes
through the leather you can't take back
that hole there's always gonna be a hole
where the needle was when I sell a
leather when they bike their skin that
leather is no longer gonna be available
to any other client oh I saw my friend
Joe and he was in this really cool red
leather jacket I want that jacket
I want that leather I won't sell it to
you we will find you another red leather
and you will have your own one-of-a-kind
piece
JAC that I'm wearing is this really
buttery soft calf skin is soaked lining
in it
storm yoke detail here silver zippers
and people feel it they're like oh my
gosh what is that the third step
involves cutting we lay out all of the
skins we examine each skin for any nicks
or holes any scratches that we may not
want on the jacket some others are more
distressed already and they show natural
grain from the animal and so you want
that in the jacket how are all 50 of
these pattern pieces going to actually
fit into these hides that are all
different sizes each one is was a
different animal
[Music]
the embroidery it's a lot of fun and
it's something that we offer most
specifically on the windings of
everyone's jackets and give people an
opportunity to have this like very
personal interior detail and it could be
anything their nickname or an
illustration it's as private detail that
no one knows about because it's on the
inside of their jacket
[Music]
the fourth seven the process of making a
jacket you have to do things like
stabilize certain areas like the waist
bands the cuff and the collars diving
the weather if it's too thick basically
cuts the thickness of the leather in
half gets rid of the bulk so that when
you have seams to fold over it doesn't
add really any extra to that which
allows the seams to actually lay flatter
it's really just a matter of like
getting all of the pieces ready to be so
[Music]
the fifth phase is where we actually sit
down and sew the pieces together it's
not necessarily okay we're gonna sit
down on some machine it's all gonna be
done like you sew one seam and then you
have to iron it flat and roll it out and
glue the seam so that everything stays
really flush and flat
we just moved into our studio downtown
Nashville it's in a neighborhood called
Pye town which is a very up-and-coming
area I've been here for three and a half
years I've lived in London for five
years which is where I studied I have
lived in San Francisco I grew up in
Alabama there's a spirit about Nashville
that it's just really great within the
few years that I was here I felt this
growth happen and it's still happening
there's no second thought in my head of
anything else I would rather be doing
there is a leather jacket for everyone
that's why I'm here is to basically help
create these pieces that even if it's
someone who has never been able to
envision themselves in a leather jacket
we can we can make that jacket
the most important part of identifying
one of my jackets is the visible logo
which is stamped in 22 karat gold on
each jacket the second is the fit
especially when viewed from the side I
create this very specific curve on every
jacket that I do slightly higher in the
back and it drops really beautifully
down to the front and then we deliver
the jacket
[Music]
leather jackets always look their best
ten years after you've had them the most
beautiful thing to me on a leather
jacket when I see someone wearing one is
the creases in the arm because that
elbow like stretches out but you can
really just see like now that you know
I've been wearing this when it's always
got this like really beautiful crease
going on every experience that you have
in that jacket something evolves in that
material it's like modern-day armor
because it gives you this like
confidence that you really don't get
from any other piece of clothing you put
on your leather jacket and you feel like
you can walk out the door and take on
the world
you
[Music]
you